Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
okay, hey, okay, okay,
thief.
I'm like still I feel still jet logged.
I don't know.
Oh, my gosh.
Hello, welcome in, welcome.
Welcome in my my boo.
Ace combat 8888 is finally real no more coping the ace
combat summon ritual was a success I feel it's every time I
don't watch these dang these dang direct awards whatever
whatever the thing that I want is announced it's every that
i that i don't watch the thing that i like i think last time
before this it was fatal frame and then time before that um
i didn't get to watch the game awards or rather i didn't get
to stream the game awards when they announced astro bot as
game of the year
Oh yeah, Tomodachi Live Wait No, Tomodachi Live though I was
streaming that one Yeah, I did get Tomodachi Live
Do Astro Boy game Oh my gosh, Nimmy is so funny She was like
Astro Boy
Oh my gosh, it's so funny After After Ace Combat 8 was
announced, I had Gabe Jeff message me and he was like, he
was like, the Hornet, it's the Hornet.
And then what's funny too is just a couple comments, but I
got a couple people going back to my Hornet tour from last
year and being like, wait a second, this VTuber teased that
Ace Combat 8 was coming because...
Because the guy said that the team, Project Ace, came to the
Hornet to do 3D scans.
No Half-Life 3.
But hey, we got that new Apex game.
Woo!
Oh yeah.
Honestly though, okay.
I'm not even so high or like so into Mega Man like I've
never played this series or anything like that but hearing
um hearing uh the song like the orchestral version of the
song while like the countdown happened and like the the the
door opening and then you see little Mega Man and you're It
was like so, it was so awesome.
Half-Life 3 sacrifices so long.
Yeah, let's be real.
I don't know.
I was going to say, let's be real.
We'll never get Half-Life 3, but I don't know.
At this point, anything could happen.
I saw you got all Ace Combat games.
I have most.
I think I'm missing a couple.
But I've been trying to collect them all.
I've been trying to.
hmm so they would never announce it at a show like this you
think so i don't know don't say never never say never never
say never thanks for sending the cutest pizza delivery girl
the greatest pizza are in all of london but it's so funny um
even uh just a couple weeks ago i think it was before I left
for Japan, I was going to do the first Ace Combat.
It's very short, so I was like, I'll just do that.
And then I was like, no, I think I'll start them as kind of
like a series.
So I pushed it back.
Now I'm like, well, dang it.
Mint foresaw the new Ace Combat game with her future side
again.
I can't stop winning.
Druids.
The Druids.
Thank you guys so much for all the super chats.
Thank you.
Super cool.
Wait, look at Super Cool Minto.
You get a 1 Plus from me.
Sorry for calling you out, Shalkin, on your lock screen.
It's just I recognize it.
And I was like, whoa, 1 Plus, 1 Plus user over here.
Can I get some of that?
Zuz, Zuz, Zuz, Zuz, Zuz.
They have announced Half-Life 3 if you had completed the
ritual like a goat head's ass to you.
Hello, Minto.
Hi.
Thank you for 20 months.
Thank you.
I was crying when I saw it.
I believe that.
Oh my gosh.
It's very exciting though.
I know that was probably not like the biggest announcement
for a lot of people.
And honestly, I had a feeling Expedition 33 was going to
sweep.
I don't know anything about that game except that people
love it.
So I was like, I think Expedition 33 is going to take the
gold this year.
Where does the time go?
Lego Island, so nostalgic.
Yeah, I used to play Lego Island when I was a little wee
wisp.
And I was like, you know what?
Why not just play it again, right?
You can actually play this like...
I'm playing this on my browser.
Hmm.
So, yeah, we're just gonna be chilling today with some Lego
Island.
It'll be a good time.
Good time, good time.
Question of the day.
Did you ever go to that e-sports thing someone emailed you
about?
E-sports?
Gin Loves!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, happy birthday!
Oh, the high school!
I'll be honest, I've been so busy.
I have, no.
Guys, my plate is...
My plate is overflowing.
I have too many things to do, unfortunately.
Moe moe boo, some Friday night pizza funds for you.
Thanks, Takeso!
I already got pizza, so thank you.
I got pizza!
I got it.
So, yeah.
Pitzer Friday, baby.
Vivikoi, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for all the welcome or welcome back.
Thank you everybody for returning to Membush.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I played this game and I really don't remember so much about
it.
So, so we're just gonna vibe with it.
So we're just gonna, we're just gonna have a chill time and
have, have a good time.
And I will count this towards the number of games that I
need to beat this year.
So, yeah.
Let's run the game, baby.
We gotta put in our CD.
Our CD-ROM.
Oh my god.
Is the bit rate okay?
Why is it so...
Like, spooky.
So loud!
Oh my god, Twin Peaks!
Twin Peaks!
Oh my god.
How many frames per second is this?
Whoa!
Oh my god.
I'm like, it's all kind of coming back to me.
I'm the pizza delivery dude, the dude with the food.
Oh, Lee.
Be careful, Pebble.
Way cool.
Oh, yeah.
I'm the dude with food.
I'm the pizza delivery dude.
Oh, my God.
They crashed.
They're dead.
Oh, my God.
That guy's the cat.
Decapitated!
Oh yeah, jailbreak.
Oh my god, every...
This place seems like a hellscape.
That guy is literally decapitated.
This gore.
Hello.
Welcome and welcome.
Konnichiwa.
Aloha.
How you doing?
Yo.
And in any language, Welcome to Lego Island!
Oh, I almost forgot!
If you haven't done so already, select our big blue brick
book and sign in, please!
Okay!
Thank you so much for the brick!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Welcome, eh, welcome, welcome.
These noises.
Woo!
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
thank you so much for the gifted paperback thank you so much
for the gifted i think we're in purgatory let's let's click
on our book and sign on in baby do i go thank you so much
for the book it's a thank you well that was interesting you
know i don't tell everybody this but here's what you do yeah
select the letters in your name then click the check mark
when you're done Why don't you tell everybody that?
Oh my god, the sound is like all over the place.
Why don't you tell everybody?
It's a guest book, you know?
Why are we gatekeeping?
Who's the others?
Oh!
Okay, let's get started.
There's music, though.
Oh my god.
Things like racing and jet skiing and building and flying
and watching and driving and having fun and...
Yeah.
Well, you know, I'm not exactly sure what all there is to
do.
Just ask my friends.
You know, the only way to visit Lego Island is to become a
Lego person.
So if you click on who you want to be and drag your choice
to where you want to go on the map, you're there.
If you need me to tell you any more, just click on me.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I have to keep adjusting the music like crazy.
Classic game, looking forward to it.
He played this.
Yeah, me too.
I made pizza last night, so it was a pizza Thursday.
Unfortunately, my chicken and pickle pizza didn't taste as
good as the pizza shops.
Pickle?
Pickle a chicken.
That sounds like a Chick-fil-A sandwich.
Why does it sound like three?
Three soundtracks are playing at once.
Critical gamer intel.
The optional jukebox song brick by brick in this game gets
content ID'd by YouTube.
No way!
This game is old enough that it should be...
It should be like a free property at this point.
No?
Thank you for the gift of that key!
Hope your frame rate will be okay.
The turning speed in this game is based on the frame rate.
What's a bug for this game?
Well, we'll find out, I suppose.
Yeah, public domain!
Let's see.
So when I was testing this last night, my favorite thing was
clicking on everything and watching him like freak out.
What?
And now...
That didn't work as well as it did before.
My score cube!
Will you win a race or deliver a pizza?
Where else are we going?
What is this?
Oh!
Why does this second story lead me to a...
Speed-owned man!
Wait, why are we in the ocean?
Big Mac, thank you for the bike and the thank you.
What?
Why does the second story bring me here?
Where does the third story bring us to?
The roof?
Who would have thought?
It's
time to let go of your remaining sanity.
Lego?
My ego!
We get such a nice view.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, my God.
Whoa, our...
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how do I make this guy not green anymore?
Okay, that's normal, right?
What is this?
Deploy!
There's a monkey in the closet.
Release them!
Peace them!
Be free!
My monkey army!
What's in here?
Another map.
Wait, what's in here?
I ain't opening the door for no man or woman alive.
So be gone with you.
And don't go in my secret cave, neither.
It's on the northwest side of the island.
Do not knock on me door there.
Don't go to my secret island cave.
Let me tell you the exact location.
I'll tell you one tiny clue if you leave me be.
Yeah?
And that's this.
If ye want to pause your game at any time to count your gold
coin, like I'm doing now, then click your pause on the pause
button right up there on your keyboard.
There's a pause button on my keyboard.
If you want to pause your game, press the pause button.
I literally...
That made no sense at all.
There used to be.
No, there didn't.
What is this?
Oh, it's like the sun in the...
Whoa.
God.
Oh my gosh.
Combat!
Ace Combat!
Dog Fight!
It's gonna be so funny when I played through the Ace Combat
series and people are like, oh my gosh, she loves Ace Combat
so much.
She must be so good at the games and they're gonna see how
bad I am at dog fighting.
Is this the first floor?
Unlimited power!
oh
my keyboard still has a pause button am i out of touch
oh the page is slowing down fire do you guys see that
no no it's okay just keep going you got this
it happened again let's let's go somewhere else do i need to
refresh we didn't get really anywhere i could just refresh
and all
okay it's time to refresh everybody wait refresh f5 f5 stop
f5 there we go okay we run it back run it back
Oh, no, or did it not save?
Wait, but this all worked yesterday!
Don't be like this game, please!
No!
It worked all yesterday!
I was clicking all over!
No way, it was the...
I released too many monkeys, maybe.
I think I released too many monkeys.
No!
Have you closed your browser since yesterday?
Of course!
I even shut down my PC.
I shut down my PC every night.
No!
Might want to try a Chromium browser.
Oh, maybe, right?
Hmm, maybe, maybe.
It might be Firefox.
I tried it on Firefox yesterday, though.
Hmm.
Okay.
That's all right, we're doing it live, we're doing it live.
Let's see.
Okay, hold on.
Let me open Chrome.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Good thing I turned off the audio.
I had like a video that was auto-playing.
Let's see.
Lego.
Lego Island.
You're playing the browser version.
Yeah.
That's what I said at the beginning.
It's so funny.
Let's see.
We're on game.
All right, hold on.
Wait.
And red to blue.
Depending upon who you are, you'll see inside or out.
I'm busy Google Chrome I wonder if it'll I don't want you
guys to see my tabs all it is
now that I see them my tabs are just Metal Gear figures if
you don't like what you see you can change it
There are Metal Gear figures on eBay.
Click on me.
Stop!
Shut up, old man.
Shut up.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Oh, okay.
I think it's cropped properly.
Okay, good.
All right, we're good.
We're good.
Good enough.
We're good enough.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
I think it's cropped properly.
I think so.
It looks like it.
Oh, there's like...
Hold on.
Let me fix it just a little bit.
There we go.
Hold on.
Why is it a little bit wider than before?
Okay.
We're doing it live.
Okay, let's just get into it.
and hope that we can play some.
Well, that was interesting.
You know.
Maybe too many O's.
Okay.
I'm gonna be the pizza boy.
I'm gonna go to pizza.
And now, your pepper.
Welcome to Lego.
I thought he was gonna say I'm pizza.
Your pizza.
Oh, for goodness sakes.
What in the blue bricks was I thinking?
I forgot to tell you one more.
thing yeah if you want to help out in the pizzeria yeah
delivering lego island's tastiest combustibles yeah click on
the pizzeria someone will show you what to do okay on the
other hand if you don't want to do that you shouldn't walk
in and say hello that's always oh this guy's walking in slow
motion behind us hi oh my god
Oh!
She's gonna go jam?
Oh my god.
The sensitivity is kind of...
Oh, I changed her!
I changed her hair!
Bald?
Everybody becomes bald.
Wait, okay.
Let's click on the pizza.
Oh my god!
This takes me back.
Holy cow.
Alright.
Hey, Pepper.
What do you think of this?
Nice, isn't it?
That's a nice!
would be nicer if you let him get to work papa why are you
so grouchy i got a bad feeling i could feel it in my knees
papa you why do they all just kind of take themselves apart
imagining knees jailbird welcome the membership thank you
flippy hooka welcome back oh my god their phone is a bird
nothing makes sense okay we'll send it out bye all right the
jail the jail but anyway Papa, take this pizza to the jail.
Take this pizza to the jail.
Whoa.
Hurry back when you're done.
Papa wants the mud sack.
Get out of my face.
Oh my god.
All right, to the jail.
Where's the jail?
Oh!
I think that's the jail.
Oh my god.
How do I move?
okay here we go that's the that's the jail though Lego I can
get through you I can get through hey pepper what up pizza
to the jail dude it's on the east side of the island over
the little bridge you know where it is but it doesn't know
where you are that's not the jail I don't know what is north
you guys keep saying like east west i don't know this looks
like a jail this is the police
oh that's a jail maybe i got my pizza in hand bring the
pizza over here pepper nick said i should keep it for him no
pizzazz at last now i will be able to ah this isn't jalapeno
red pepper anchovy double garlic pizza i need a It's not
your fault, Peppa.
You're a good kid.
What's it like on the outside?
I heard that you can fly a helicopter around the island now.
You should try it.
Helicopters are a lot of fun.
I think he wants me to kill myself.
What is that?
I like, I don't remember anything about this game besides
like the...
the running around like this you know wait i think i went i
think i think i took lego lego
and a gracious howdy do to you i think she's flipping me off
you guys
i wish i didn't have to just stay on the road let me let me
go crazy with it Best pizza on the island, even if it wasn't
the only pizza on the island.
I just ate 10 quadruple garlic and bean pizzas while
listening to songs on the jukebox.
Oh, I love that jukebox.
And I love those quintuple anchovies.
Oh, I love those jukebox.
I think I'll go listen to the jukebox and eat about 10 more
of these.
Houston, I think we may have a problem.
Oh, my God.
What?!
Nothing makes sense!
Hello!
Okay, we'll send it out.
Bye.
Yep.
That was the jail.
It sounded like Nick.
But anyway, Papa take this pizza to the jail.
Another pizza to the jail?
There must be a party at the county jail.
Yeah.
I hope that ambulance isn't trying to murder me again.
There it is.
Why is it doing this?
What's happening?
What is...
Are those just a bunch of seals?
Oh, they're sharks, I think.
And ghosts!
Oh my gosh, look how cute they are!
Hey, hey, wait, there's people inside.
Oh.
Did you see that?
I saw somebody's head.
Yeah, there's people in there.
Hey, Pepper, what up?
Pizza to the jail, dude.
It's on the east side of the island over the little bridge.
You know where it is, but it doesn't know where you are.
Oh, I thought it was these guys talking to me before.
Hey, Pepper.
Hello?
I hope they...
Oh.
Yeah, pepperoni again?
Oh, who does a guy have to con to get a jalapeno red
pepperoni?
pepper anchovy double garlic pizza around here it's a kid
build that helicopter yet flying around not a care in the
world you should try it it's fun is that why you're in jail
what I kind of want to build the helicopter now though how
do I build the helicopter you shouldn't
do that sir the lights about to change
Pepper, be careful.
Remember that skateboard of yours is a vehicle.
I remember it is, and I remember everything.
In fact, I just remember that I said I remember everything.
10-4, good buddy.
Let's go to the police station.
Oh, it's quiet on the eastern side of the island.
Well, if you overlook it, the flying legando and and the
Lego what was that and well well of course Mrs. Post's hair
is stuck in a car again why is the bird driving the car
again chasing Joaquin the dog and well well Nuby won't stop
talking about the mysteries of life and actually well it's
not very quiet at all oh oh oh
I can't...
I literally...
I have nothing to say because it's just...
Oh.
It's just so all insane.
What's happening?
Oh gosh, they're going crazy.
in the donuts oh my god oh yeah what did that do oh here's
the helicopter yeah my man oh i'm bill ding building and
i'll just put this cop cap on here and whoa attention snap
to it howdy is just kidding it's the hat talking not me
anyway back to building so you volunteered to build the
helicopter yep negative select the triangle and dismiss
yourself otherwise Just the facts.
One.
The switch will move the shelves to display your pieces for
building.
Okay.
Two.
The color choices are over here.
Okay.
Three.
Select this.
The chapter will rotate.
Four.
When complete, select the triangle sign.
You're on assignment.
Awesome.
Wait, how do I get that piece though?
How do I get this piece?
Is this...
Just the facts.
When complete, select the triangle sign.
And you're on assignment.
The switch will move the shelves to display your pieces.
Oh, thank you.
The color choices are over here.
Thank you.
Select this, and the copter will rotate.
Ah, here we go, here we go.
These sound effects.
Holy moly.
There's like something really...
Like, I don't mind the new Legos, but there's just something
so simple about, like...
I just don't like how curvy they are any like nowadays and
oh there's there was something so simple about Legos like
this They were so good wait.
Oh, how do I like change the color?
The old ones have charm.
I know it's probably my nostalgia talking But I just can't
get into like the new The new Legos that are they're just so
round sometimes They're just so round.
I can't get...
I know you can make more with them, but I feel like part of
the thing with Lego is like...
You had to be...
You had to get around the fact that they weren't so round.
You know what I mean?
You had to get around.
What even is this part?
What is this?
This one?
How do I change?
Oh, like this.
Ew.
Go back to black.
I'm afraid of the game crashing if I do too many things,
so...
Spoken like a true Minecraft gamer.
I'm just saying.
Oh my gosh, I almost just knocked my tea all over the place.
Oh.
Uh, this one.
This one.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, the reason I'm not changing the colors is, like I just
said, I'm afraid that if I do too much, it'll crash the
game.
Oh, wait, maybe this is the other side.
There we go.
Where did the other one go?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Why does it make this sound?
And our final piece?
Excellent job.
Now go to the helicopter pad out front to your right.
By the jail.
And prepare for takeoff.
Oh, and one more thing.
Keep an eye out for the Brickster.
The Brickster.
Oh.
Is this the police station?
Okay, let's leave.
What was that?
Why is he hitting the gritty?
The helicopter maniac?
Good job.
Let's see.
What was I gonna tell you?
Oh yeah.
The launch pad.
It's over there.
By the jail.
10-4.
Oh my god, the skib.
Is that...
Is this my skateboard?
Wow!
You're gonna have a gas on that skateboard!
If you want to get off, just put your hands down and hop
off.
Where'd he go?
What does that mean?
Just put your hands down.
The loudest sacks ever, right?
I'm sorry.
Pepper, or should I say paper?
That's how you spell it, don't you?
He just called me flat.
You can't spell or read too well.
Hey.
And illiterate.
I'm not the one in jail.
Oh!
Who else is in jail?
What's, wait, what's this button do?
Hey, condiment boy.
You know, seeing you has made me think.
We should be building schools, not prisons.
Why don't we build a school?
We could start with these bricks.
Running in place, look at him go.
Come on, you got this brickster.
You got this!
Keep going!
You'll make it out!
Why is it all concentrated in my right ear?
All right.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, whoa.
Here I am!
What's the point of this?
I just get to see everything that I want?
Oh, wait.
Maybe it's like kind of I can travel really fast.
Whoa!
Oh my god, whoa, whoa, what's up here?
Okay, just to fly around for now.
We gotta figure out, maybe I deliver more pizzas.
Wait, what's this here?
What's this place?
What's that?
Oh, okay.
Uh, get me out of this?
If you want to get back to where you were, Just click on the
big eye in front of my desk.
Okay.
See you later, Brickulator.
Just a fun little thing.
Oh.
Oh, here we go.
Okay, you click on the hands and it gets you out.
Let's go, baby.
Let's deliver more pizza.
Yeah.
There's also something out there.
Something out at sea.
Oh, this is where the lifeguard is.
Oh, I can click here.
Go to Japan Zoo!
Have fun!
Hello, I'm Bill Ding, and you're Bill Ding.
Well, just a little joke.
I really never noticed that before.
Bill Ding.
Anyway, I just put this hat on here and whoa, I'm stooped
now.
Whoa, whoa.
Aloha.
And welcome.
And you're like, here to build a boat.
A jet ski.
Okay.
That's bogus.
You can split anytime by clicking on the triangle.
Check it out.
That switch will move the shelves so you can grab your
pieces.
Okay.
Click and drag.
But drag isn't a drag.
You know what I mean.
Whoa.
And then check out the colors.
huh and then this cool panel will rotate your ski for a
better look ski and like when you're done click on the
triangle and somebody will bring your new jet ski out front
for you so like you can go totally bonkers in the bay
totally cool hey i gotta split swells off jailhouse rocks
six bricks high see you in the soup that was those Those
were words.
Those were words, everybody.
You hear all that?
Let's see.
This one now?
Wait, where's the other piece?
Am I blind?
Where's the other piece?
Hi.
It's literally not that.
Oh, it was like the lighting was kind of weird on it.
Game is made for children and I can't...
I don't know how to play.
Yeah!
Yeah, it was like an optical illusion for real.
Extremely awesome.
Okay, we'll bring it outside for you to splash in the pond.
Cool.
Thank you!
Very cool.
Oh, where'd your pants go?
The race begins when you pull up to that Rui out there.
Otherwise, you can just paddle around here.
Ciao.
There's gas in this thing?
Oh, I think something is trying to eat me.
Oh, something's trying to eat that guy.
All right?
Oh.
Was I too late?
Hey, they're cheating!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, guys.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I think I killed him, man.
But that's okay.
I might have also saved him from sharks, who knows?
Do I have to, like, touch this buoy?
Oh, I'm stuck in the mystery triangles.
Oh my god, I'm stuck in the Bermuda triangle.
Oh my god, there she goes.
Wait, how do I get out?
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Please!
No, please!
Okay, there we go.
Get off!
Where are they, though?
Watch out!
Oh, that guy's stuck in the rocks.
How is she getting any further ahead though?
It's kind of crazy.
Oh my god, it's it's so jerky.
It's like crazy.
Oh, I think I killed him.
We'll catch up.
There she is.
Oh,
we were so close!
my god is she waiting whoops jet ski pro checking in you
tore it up hey second place behind the ski champ is pretty
cool and we were robbed yourself a blue brick
congratulations okay we gotta do it again we gotta do that
again we gotta get first place for real watching it was
because i See if I needed to hit the buoys, but I was just
stupid.
They're cheating even.
Look at them.
They're getting ahead of me.
You think she'll be okay this time?
Never mind.
Heads up.
What's wrong with her?
It feels like none of these are actual obstacles.
except the triangles.
You know?
Those are the only things that actually stop me.
Okay.
And then we go again.
This guy just is a noble sacrifice.
That's why she's the champ.
She knows the strats, clearly.
They're like right behind me.
They're on my butt.
It's scary.
This is very...
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I lied.
There are actual...
obstacles oh my god they're right behind me oh my god i hear
them oh my god oh my god oh my god
it's so jerky though it's like making me sick
i'm not gonna lose oh my god it did it again you have to
like stop after the ramp or else
or else it does that oh i think i did it I mean totally
awesome dude the way you took that turn back there truly
trick and the shark and oh I'm sorry I hereby award you the
official first-place red brick yeah thank you thank you
thank you very much hey what's happening gonna build a pwc
oh you know personal watercraft a jet ski man i just got off
the beach myself swell swell i got some sand in my cap
though bubby oh oh whoa i gotta pay more attention to things
that's where it went that's cool you know what this is what
this lets you build the jet ski oh that's it when you want
to build the jet oh i already did there we go oh
Awesome!
Okay, we're so good at games.
What else we got going on around here?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, they're like a death cult.
He gets anxious, okay?
What topics?
Uh, let's see.
What toppings do I like on my pizza?
Well, you can't get mad at me.
Okay, what does it say?
Super 2.
I like...
Number 1, I like...
Pineapple.
And...
I like to also get...
Like a green pepper and spinach...
And garlic.
And...
Mmm, sometimes!
Sometimes I'll get chickpeas.
Impossibly loud, incorrect buzzer.
Ah, ah, ah!
I
like it.
It's pretty much like a veggie pizza.
Yeah.
That I like to get.
What's this?
Okay, nothing.
This guy is a freak.
over here.
Oh, where'd you come from?
He's coming to beat me up because I just made fun of him.
Okay, just kidding.
I'm trying...
We'll do more pizza delivery, but I'm also interested in
what's going... Oh, this gang is back.
It feels like stuff just happens in this game.
Yeah, really... Why do they make a chomping sound?
It really does feel that way, though.
Stuff happens.
You just let it happen.
Motor Speedway!
Ninja Turtles style toppings, maybe?
Let's get her.
Get her ass.
Take her bike.
Dang it.
Oh my god.
200 150 they're gambling hey it is legal who what's this for
littering oh my gosh you just got ticketed how do I race let
me race there we go oh yeah how ding and you're just in time
let me put this cap on here and wow birdie sporty hardware
huh i'll bet you're ready to build your car right oh yeah if
not i'd exit by hitting that triangle over here i'm pretty
busy so unless your head's falling off you're on your own i
know you're smart holy loud okay buddy the switch to move
the shells thank you thank you your paints are over there
Oh, and this witch out here will set the car around for a
better look.
When you're done, click on the triangle side and summon your
drinker out front for you to drive.
Thank you.
Good luck, little brick.
I'm out of here.
Don't ask me why.
Don't ask me how.
But I got a cat stuck in a radiator.
Gotta go.
All right, we're building Lightning McQueen.
Okay.
Do you know this place actually stands for Otaku Connolly?
convention octane octane okay the green is like if me and
lightning mcqueen had a baby oh hey snappy looking wheels
you got when did december sneak up on us it's like the
middle of december front for you oh if you want to make any
kind of changes later just come on in again
yes yes i must agree with building on your tremendously
built new race vehicle but let's see what it can do hey
enter the competition get in your car and well good luck
thank you oh there he goes there he goes we're gonna get
we're gonna own the competition oh hey pal good luck you're
gonna need it against me hold on my contact is bothering me
don't go yet ladies and gentlemen start your engines please
and go oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh wait I I remember this oh my god it's so
nostalgic Oh my god.
How many people are racing?
Is it... Oh.
Why is it death symbol?
I don't feel like I should...
Oh my god.
I don't feel like I should be in here!
Out of the way!
Oh, I thought that was somebody cheating.
We're drifting?
Why is this like the...
Oh, oh.
No way.
Wait, how far did that put me back?
So far back!
No stinking way.
Oh my god, that might have cost us the entire race, you
guys!
Please!
His legs were open!
His legs were open, I swear!
It's so over.
Oh my god, oh my god, please, okay.
We made it up?
Giant ghost!
We can, we can, we can recover!
We can recover.
We're the best to ever do it.
I think.
Try an octopus!
Okay, we're catching up.
Kind of.
Oh, what the hell?
Why does it do
it?
Don't me, don't go.
I'm trying.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know.
We're like right on their butt.
It's this guy, though!
Caught up to at least one.
To Shadow the Hedgehog.
We caught up to Shadow the Hedgehog.
Alright, please, please God.
Yes!
There's the other guy!
That's my...
Might be doable, everybody.
Everybody.
She's gaming?
Your honor?
I can't stop winning!
Giant ghost.
Is this the end?
Did I make-
Wait.
Why?
I- You- I woulda wipe you out.
But my- my colors were clashing.
Let's do this again sometime.
You sure did give me a run from my bricks.
Good race.
Yes, ma'am.
Me?
That's me!
I'm first place, baby!
Congratulations on a well-run race.
The best comeback in history.
Stud Beacon's dad, have I seen such dexterity on the track?
Very good.
Yes, very good.
You wouldn't even find this in Umu Musume.
Hereby awarded a red ring for first place.
Yeah!
Let's go!
That track was...
Painous.
This is all underneath the island?
Can I go through?
Take it.
Just a little peek.
Oh!
Wait, sir.
This road is closed.
You can't go this way, sir.
Sir, this road is closed.
A twist?
None of us could have imagined.
Woo!
Why do they get to clip through everything?
I can't even walk on the grass.
One of us?
Oh my gosh, please.
All right, so we gained...
I wish I had my...
I don't know where my skateboard is.
We got... Let's deliver some more pizza.
This soundtrack is awesome though.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, there's something...
They're just kidding.
We're doing something else.
Hello?
Hey, Peppa, how you doing?
How are those new wheels I put on for you?
It's like I say, life is like a skateboard.
No, that's not what I always say.
I know.
I always just say, how you doing?
So how you doing?
He's just like me when he tries to create a new catchphrase.
DMCA song.
I can't turn it off, you guys.
I'm trying to get over to the track right away.
It's fine.
My streams are always demonetized anyway.
Nancy, I can't go.
I've got two cars on the blocks already.
Could you do it?
I would really appreciate it.
And like I always say, you scratch my brick and I'll scratch
yours.
If you can do it, just pick up that tow truck hat so they'll
know you're working with me.
Okay.
Wait, what are we doing?
Thanks.
Truck's ready.
It's out in front.
Okay.
I wonder why it does that.
What, honk?
I don't know.
Thanks again.
really pulled my brick out of the fire.
When you get to the racetrack, race track.
Pull into the parking lot, get out of the truck, and open
the gate.
Okay.
A couple of the mechanics will take the truck down to the
track and load the car up for you.
You're doing just fine.
I'm not going anywhere.
How are the arrows?
No.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can get through this, though.
I believe.
I trust.
See?
That guy's like chilling up there too.
Okay, so we said go to here.
Oh, lift the... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
When I played Lego racer...
Thanks for the Super Chat!
Easy?
Yeah, we have...
We're hacking.
We're hacking?
We're not going far.
To pick up the toll.
So, it's off we go.
We'll be right back.
Follow us to the track.
We can do a break my brick.
New karaoke song.
How did it happen like that?
Wait, isn't that my car?
Wait, what are you doing with my car?
Wait, that's my car, no?
Wait a second!
Wait!
Mine was green.
No, it was red and green.
under control.
See you at the garage.
Okay.
This island is like two inches long.
It's a good thing you can't fix them too.
Or I'd be looking for a new line of work.
Wake.
Yeah, it was right down the street.
For a car, the first toes on me.
Well, not exactly on me.
That would hurt.
Anyway, see you around and thanks again.
Thank you!
Let's go deliver some pizza.
I don't know what do I run out of...
Do I have to keep delivering pizza for the rest of my
afterlife?
Oh.
If you spent as much time learning to read as you did on
that scale, board you'd be out of college by now hey save
some energy i i got work for you why does everybody say that
i can't read why is everybody insulting my my reading
capabilities hello hello okay we'll send it out bye that was
the jam it sounded like nick but anyway papa take this pizza
to the jail okay she didn't talk about them having a pizza
party Be careful.
Papa's got the six to sense.
The what?
The six sense?
What does that have to do with it?
What does having a six sense have to do with...
Huh?
Hawk literally just glides.
Oh, goes through your other roadblock.
I'm too good.
Great, my Nick's pizza.
I'll take that.
Uh, yeah.
Papa's famous jalapeno red pepper and he's got the pizza he
wanted on the island he's delivered just a different type of
cafe made because the sign says don't feed the brickster you
see I just put this baby near the lock and let the fumes do
their work hmm I'm out of here
oh no no okay good and I hereby pardon myself of all crimes
innocent as a newly opened box of bricks i am free to do
whatever wait and i built a helicopter too brick by brick
he's staring at me while he steals it
oh my god i am the lord of the bricks the king of the bricks
for this so fast the brick of frack long live the brickster
i can't hear you over the helicopter what did he just what
was that wait what oh jailbreak situation red situation is
beyond red whatever that color would be the brickster has
escaped I repeat the brickster has escaped yikes he took the
master don't tell me you had anything to do with this that
plastic punk tricked you didn't he say no more I know how
you feel.
No time for your touchy-feely stuff now.
Come in, Infomaniac.
Just interrupted her.
Infomaniac.
And yes, there is reason to get overly excited.
There you are.
But that won't help this terrible situation at all.
Everybody's talking at once.
Calm down.
Who is that?
But what was going through here somewhere?
Why is everybody talking?
Calm down.
I might be able to remember what it is.
Stop a nut.
So why did it do?
I hear the helicopter.
It went behind the hill.
The mountain park.
West, that way.
Okay.
Ah, yes!
The solution!
I remember what it is.
What?
Okay, so the brickster has stolen the helicopter.
Yes.
And the power brick from atop our information center.
He must have taken off to the other side of the island as
Mama just heard.
So we...
Yes.
And I remember now that's where he went the last time he
escaped.
By the residential area.
By that cave.
by northwest so we need someone to race over there someone
who could use a vehicle that can travel on roads and paths
over ramps and in a jiffy a skateboard perhaps a skateboard
we need someone who someone maybe like you exactly like you
and we'll meet you over there head out to the residential
you guys also have bikes and are also the police and i am a
child head west perfect a plan okay you race over there and
find the brickster Watch his every move and wait for Nick
and Laura to show up.
I'll be at the information center to figure out our next
move.
Before the brickster has a chance to do whatever destiny is.
The illiterate child.
I had plenty of time to come up with some scheme while in
jail.
Be careful, Pepper.
Yeah.
Hurry, Pepper.
Be careful.
Hurry up, Pepper.
I'll go make us a pizza.
Well, I just can't.
attributed to something terrible in this town, huh?
Wait, is my skateboard over there?
Where is my skateboard?
Attention, Pepper!
If you can hear me, go to the residential area by the
mountain through the tunnel to the far west side of the
island.
Hurry!
I don't know what is north or south or east or west.
I think I'm stupid.
It must be up here, right?
They said behind the mountains?
Hurry!
Here to fight demonetization.
Thank you so much!
Don't worry about it at all.
Police sanction skateboarding?
Brist preposterous?
The bricks are loose!
I don't think she's all that concerned.
Wait, what is this?
Lost?
Then go to the pizzeria.
I'll help you get to the tunnel from the there no no i'll
get there i'll get there information for the cut scenes is
actually played within the audio track as computers at the
time needed to squeeze out every ounce of power they could
oh palpable panda thank you so much for the 20 hinted i
guess that would explain why like the audio track like is
reset and everything dmca yes i mean no oh oh well at least
you got here too much damage we got most of the blockades
down already here's the deal we've got to hey folks small
world ain't it it's about to get smaller I mean you're on an
island this guy has a helicopter the ambulance was stolen
and we think the bricksters plan is to take apart the town
oh my god he's eating the trees!
Follow us.
Oh, whoa.
Okay, plan A.
Why do they sound Canadian sometimes?
Nick, you check out the east side.
See if you can't head him off at the path.
Pepper, follow him and click on everything he drops.
We need it as evidence.
Let's do it, team.
Keep on it, son.
Oh, I get to go now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's really...
Oh my god, oh my god!
Whoa!
I'm shaking my bricks now!
Hey, Peppa, deliver this!
I got it!
I took it!
I don't think... I think we don't need any evidence.
I think we...
know exactly.
Should I be faster?
Music is crazy.
Oh, wait, where'd he go?
Uh-oh.
That way.
Didn't she get a map in the instruction booklet?
No!
I hear him.
Oh, my God.
He's really destroying stuff.
Whoa, what is this?
Wait, I just found a hidden treasure.
Wait, this is the guy that was talking about the hidden
treasure.
Oh, we have to come back.
Uh-oh.
He's destroying the town.
The
pirate...
How is he driving like that?
What's wrong with Lego Island?
Why doesn't he just leave the island?
Why?
We're on like the tiniest island ever.
Why can't we just get him?
It's the mean, mean pizza machine.
That's me, baby.
I wish I had my skateboard.
Hey, Pepper.
Did you order the...
Brick?
Good one, Brickster.
Good one.
You really got me there.
You really owned me with that one.
God, he's so fast.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
He shoots!
He scores!
And how long am I supposed to do this for?
Ahhhh!
Achoo!
Must be the pepper in the air.
You may be able to catch a brick, but you can't catch me
too.
Long enough.
Hey!
You're blocking the road, kid!
I'm behind you!
I'm here!
There he goes.
Where is it?
What's he grabbing next?
I didn't, like, when you, like, dismantle Legos, I didn't
think I don't think that they would like, you know, shrink
like that.
Oh, oh, oops, I clicked out of there.
I clicked out of the tab, that's why.
I don't think I'm on the skateboard at all.
I'm just running.
I don't know where my skateboard is.
Does mint come with the pizza?
No, I'm just here to deliver it, baby.
Oh, my God, he's so fast.
Oh, he's going to the pirate.
There's nothing down there for you.
Let's stop making that noise.
Let's stop doing that.
Fine, I'll hide the rest so I can rest.
Oh, my God, please.
Great job, pal.
Why is he making that sound?
They are the pieces of the helicopter, so we...
And the bad news is, we're still missing four pieces.
No!
We've got to cover this island like studs on a brick.
Pepper, check everywhere.
Everywhere?
Click on it when you find one.
Okay.
Well, there's this one right here.
Oh, no.
No, no.
No, we're not gonna do that.
Wait, how do I stop that?
How do I stop that sound?
They're everywhere.
Wait.
Oh, it's when, like, a thing.
Oh, my God.
It's like a...
It's like an alert to tell me where the...
Where the brick is.
Oh, God.
Okay.
We gotta play the game to stop the...
To save ourselves.
I think I hear one up here, though.
You hear?
it just me oh my god oh my god i think we're okay without i
think we can find it without without any uh odd audible
clues i think we're okay wait there's nothing up here just
kidding uh i'm oh oh there's a man this is just kidding
there's something else thank you so much for the read Why is
there's like two different soundtracks playing on top of
each other?
Three, two, two, two, three, two, two, two, two, two, two,
two, two, two, three.
Thank you, y'all!
Thank you!
Out of the way!
Hello, everybody.
Coming in, we're playing Lego Island!
accidentally assisted in a jailbreak and now we are um we
are suffering the karma
oh i think it's that right there oh my god we're so close
and yet so far i think they said it was what four out of the
way grandma Come on!
We're suffering the karma of our actions.
So then what?
We got...
Is this the last one?
I guess we'll see.
I wish I had my skateboard, but I do not know where it is.
Okay, the closer we get.
There we go.
And boo.
There's one more somewhere.
Wait, I hear two.
I think.
You can click the pieces from anywhere.
No way.
Really?
What is it?
Which one?
Just turn it off.
Is it behind?
Okay.
Very good.
Let me out.
Let me out of this hellscape.
There's There's one more.
Well, there it is.
Wait, so if I see it...
Oh!
Those policemen couldn't hear the whistling?
It's probably like a dog whistle.
They're too old.
They can't hear it with their big adult age.
Ears.
Pepper is our best and most proven builder.
Quickly, get to the police station and build our helicopter.
I'll meet you there at the launching pad.
You're done.
I think we have a plan.
Hurry!
All right, let's go.
Now the police station will be whistling.
Oh!
Whoa, I'll get out of your way.
We're a better builder than I, so go to it.
Thank you.
Yeah, out of my way, out of my way.
Let the professionals handle this.
Oh, oops, I skipped it.
All right.
Master builders, though, like Lego master builders are kind
of scary.
They're so good.
Yeah, don't forget the rocket launcher.
Pepper, good luck.
Fly right.
Wait, me?
Check your angle of projection.
Aim in front of the brickster and toss some donuts our way.
It'll speed us up and slow him down.
We're a team now.
Good luck, partner.
Aim right, Pepper.
I don't want to be spinning on any pizzas.
Good luck.
Wait, what am I doing?
You're the police!
What am I?
Oh, Pepper, be careful up there.
Can you hear me, Pepper?
This is Mama.
It sounds like you're chewing well.
Mama!
Yes.
What's happening?
Oh, Pepper.
Pepper will make you free pizzas for a week if you can get
that stuff.
Oh, no!
Wait.
Hold on.
What's happening?
They didn't give me anything.
Any...
Remember, this is the little bickeroon.
You're looking good, little buddy.
You're on that picture like a pair of...
I'd rather cause chaos.
I'd like something.
Pepper, good talk.
I wish I was up there with you, good buddy.
Looks like you're having a quick, quick good time.
Where's the police?
Oh, you guys.
Come on, come on.
Go, please.
Where do you go?
Oh, there he is.
He's heading to the pizzas.
He's hungry again.
No, no, no.
Oh, good.
He's going to.
there he's going towards him now wait where'd he go where'd
the police officer go no why did you turn around oh my god
oh my god I only where are you going Why?
That's the target.
What?
Officer!
Thank you, Pepper.
Just the energy boost I needed.
Wait, did I lose?
It's mine!
the boulder rolling off the cliff well it's not as bad as it
looks well maybe it is no actually you can just start again
or come back later when you want to we'll be able to
reconstruct i think oh what am i saying of course we can
we're the citizens of lego island so start a new game Or
exit through those doors and come back when you want to
visit again.
Start a new game?
What's kind of messed up is that there were so many
buildings that were already destroyed because I took so long
because I didn't have my skateboard chasing the dang
ambulance around.
And so he only had like two things to eat up at the very
end.
wait okay hold on and now you're pepper welcome to lego
island
roguelike i think a real star
wait what's my what's my cube looking like oh my yes your
score cube when you win a race or deliver a pizza you'll
earn your brick whether you're pepper mama or and the rest
red is best blue is second yellow third and with gray you
haven't even started yeah enter a race or go to the beach
and come back and check your score oh I almost forgot that
book over there on the shelf yeah entitled the history of
the best scores ever played on Lego Island part one and it's
all about well me the best score wait who's the best score
it's what if it's what if it's me
okay let's try being this lady or something i don't know i
don't know laura brick laura brick i salute you okay oh oh
it's you you're not under arrest but but I'm watching you
you're probably here to build a helicopter well it's about
time for lunch no no no I just ate well wait I just ordered
in oh no order order in the court you're under arrest oh oh
it's still you is he building a Lego set useful and build a
helicopter snap to it at ease I like you kid what he said so
much and nothing at the same time.
I didn't say a single word to him and he just kept going
off.
Like, why I have to build all of these again?
Wait, it's built.
I'll get out of your way.
You're a better builder than I, so go to it.
It's already done.
If I want to make it green.
Everything.
Green.
What?
Wait a second.
Why doesn't it make it green?
Just the facts.
When complete.
Yep.
I tried.
Now go to the helicopter pad out front to your right.
By the jail.
And prepare for takeoff.
Oh, and one more thing.
Keep an eye out for the Brickster.
You guys never look at me, though, and think, dang, she's
cute.
But I'm so confused how I'm supposed to complete that
minigame Or the like the final boss, you know Is he gonna be
released?
Wait, my skateboard is here Oh, it says pizza!
Oh my god, I couldn't read Because I am I was a stupid kid I
actually couldn't read!
It said pizzazz!
Oh my god!
The attention to detail!
I can't believe it!
I actually can't believe it right now.
Hey, no visiting!
The visiting hours are over!
Wait, so do I have to deliver pizzas?
It's so nice to see you.
Your smile always reminds me of a song.
Just don't ask Papa to sing it.
Earlier, why did they keep calling me illiterate?
I can't believe it!
I can't believe I was actually illiterate!
I found enough ingredients in the kitchen to make 151
pizzas.
151 pizzas?
If we're so busy around here, we'll probably have to make
150 pizzas.
151.
150 pizzas, 151 pizzas.
If we don't get some help delivering, we're going to have
150 unhappy customers.
Hello, Laura.
Hi.
How can we help the Lego Islands finally?
Well, I'll tell you how she can help us.
Laura, we're in a spot.
I need Pepper to deliver a bunch of pizzas.
Yeah?
Enter and return just ordered one for the hospital.
Okay.
Would you please take it to them?
To the hospital?
I don't think I've been there yet.
Oh, thank you, Laura.
I know this will be the safest pizza on the island.
Pepper's gonna...
You have to take my skateboard.
I'll bet you'll be a real riding Betty.
Wait, I'm gonna take the skateboard?
You're cruising, doing some switchbacks, tail sides, or
going 540, and a bar comes up.
Do you grind it or sniff it?
Sniff?
Just don't fall down.
I have a actual vehicle.
I need.
Let go.
Okay, here we go.
What's the hospital?
Oh, that must be it up there.
There's kittens in the road!
This guy...
Wait, excuse me.
Excuse me.
You must skate.
It's like the...
It's some of the...
requirements of being a delivery boy now this is my kind of
emergency the pizza is nice and hot i think the patient
shall live oh what if what if i didn't deliver it
what if i had never delivered it wait a second though when
we're on our way back or rather when we're back i want to
I wanted to go check out the pirate area.
Everybody knows that.
But I can dance.
So what I meant to say is that you look so lovely that I
could dance.
Pep are you good?
Did I complete the mission?
There we go.
Can I actually run out of gas on this thing?
Does it actually go down?
Wait, I need to go the other way.
Disassociating hard.
For real.
Oh, hey, darling.
Oh.
What brings you by Nubbies?
I'll bet you wanted to see one of the seven wonders of Lego
Island.
Well, that's us, all right.
We're open 24-7, and for some reason...
It does.
That's crazy.
I never get tired.
Hmm.
Of course, I'm a nervous wrench.
Oh.
Say, if you're here to build a car, go on inside, and it's
the next door on the right.
If you're not, go on in anyway.
Now you'll be just drilled to see you.
Drilled?
Sorry about the pun.
I'm auditioning for the Lego Island Talent Show.
What's the talent?
Don't quit your day job.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, she filled me up, though.
Wait, maybe Lego Island is amazing.
Gas is free.
Wee!
Awesome.
Arr, I needs me beauty sleeves.
Go away.
If an I tell you's a secret, will you go away?
Yeah.
I, of course you would.
Try clicking on the shift button on your keyboard and then
moving your mouse around to steer.
It won't hurt your finger as much.
But when you want to click on something else, click on the
shift again before you do to take it out of the easy to
drive mode
What was that?
We'll bounce me bricks if it ain't you again I'll tell you
one more secret if in your go away.
You can move around the island just by using the arrow keys
on your keyboard.
Try that one and leaves me alone.
How do you think I got here?
It's not a secret.
You know, you can take loverly pictures any place on the
island just by clicking on the print screen button on your
keyboard and opening your Windows paint program if and when
you got one and then pasting her in.
You know what?
Okay.
Thank you, Mr.
dang i was really hoping for some real like secret but
whatever so the shift key does what the shift key doesn't do
anything i think it doesn't do anything i see no difference
i knocked my head up last week and i lost my memory for a
while what happened i don't remember i knocked my head off
last week and lost my memory for a while whoa whoa guys i
don't know what's happening my hand is literally off the
keyboard guys oh okay we're fine you first no you first oh
please you first i press shift I don't know if I should
trust the hospital.
Arr, you get to get the task manager with control alt
delete.
You can change windows with alt text.
Arr!
I see you now, of course, and I'm really glad you're here.
I'm going to pieces as you can see it.
Seems like everybody picked a day to fall apart on me.
Okay.
Oh, I just left.
Sorry.
Wait.
No, what's going on in here?
oh oh my god oh my god gore oh my god it's horrible it's
terrible next time you stop the trap
how do i oh this is bad very bad i need to get an ambulance
to all of those locations and all of my drivers are out with
a bad case of the bumps you know what you can do this you
can drive the ambulance of course why didn't i think of that
before well of course it wasn't an emergency before but it
is now take enter and return with you they'll know what to
do enter return come out here i need you coming outgoing ah
oh my god we're i'm joining the three stooges since when do
you wear that color why does he sound so familiar don't
worry they'll get it together they always do don't forget to
take the ambulance hat the ambulance is parked right outside
okay the ambulance hat oh i'm glad you're going they'll need
some claw holding and you have the best brick-side manner on
this island
we gotta have this and this can't go without the shark I
hope there's room for the tree and what do we do if it's hot
out there these guys what if we have to mail a letter I want
to kill them let me do my job Try to figure out your
shortest route.
It doesn't matter which order.
Just hurry.
When you get to the locations, someone there will tell you
what to do.
What's the location?
I have no idea where I'm going.
Uh, I'm doing Easy Drive.
I don't know what Easy Drive does.
The music, like, doesn't match the scenario.
In the headlines today, Brickster's still here.
in jail disaster at the beach parrot makes painters plunge a
nick in time saves nine building reaches an all-time high
legos in space more later where where am i supposed to go
what's north
delete your history by hitting control h the pizza oh my god
is papa having a heart attack is he choking on pizza I'll
get to you Papa Papa that's the only ambulance so if you
wreck it we don't have another one to send for you oh my god
someone else is dying Papa!
Oh, there's our obstacles.
Some dude!
Oh, okay.
I'll click on him.
Oh, he seems fine.
Oh my god, easy mistake.
Don't worry.
If we can't save it, we can make it tomorrow night special.
Oh my god.
Everything is choking.
Even the dog is choking.
Dog ate the cat and the cat is choking.
We gotta put up a sign.
No pets allowed.
Me, is it hard to get some slave around here or what?
It's a nasty dog joke.
Okay.
Well, don't drop him!
You mean like that other guy?
What ever happened to him?
Who?
The other guy.
We dropped him!
Well, don't drop him!
Okay.
Keep going.
You're doing great.
Where's the other place, though?
Um...
At least we don't have to rebuild everything.
That's kind of nice.
This is a fever dream for real, y'all.
Uh, PlayStation?
Oh, yes.
You're still in time.
No one's calling yet.
Hey, you see, there's this way.
I guess we destroyed this sleep or something.
We destroyed the sleep.
What I need you to do is get your clown boys over there to
hold the stretcher under the roof and catch my partner when
he comes.
Oh my god.
Why is the parrot attacking him?
Not that he needs any help.
But I can't help myself.
You should click on the gate up there.
Then, when the page are false, return and enter can catch
him.
Oh.
At the gate.
That red stripe will drop in the driveway.
Oh, you already knew that.
Sorry.
Yep.
Yeah.
Someone destoibed his sleep.
Okay, let's bring them on home.
Oh, not to my home, of course.
It's just the victim of speech.
Bring them home.
You heard the man.
Oh, sorry.
This is so goofy.
Birdemic Lego crossover?
The music, though, it's so chill.
It's putting me to sleep.
Oh.
never seen such good driving you're a regular stud slinking
well i suppose i should get back to my practice uh although
i don't know why they call it that practice i i am a doctor
already i don't really need to practice it's sort of
redundant it's actually a little insulting stud slinking
studs lincoln uh did i get a did i get did i get a red brick
for that So I guess I'm guessing I have to keep delivering
pizzas.
Or do I have to do everything to unlock the final level, the
jail, you know?
Officer Brick, check it out.
Mama wrote me a theme song.
360 degree rotation and I'm still pushing Mongo foot in.
Am I a rad ripper or what?
You can only do the story playing as Pepper, if I remember
correctly.
him way oh because he's the one that get that makes him
break out of jail oh so then maybe we have to redo the story
as pepper oh I picked the right guy the very first time
that's crazy are you ready to leave Lego Island no oh bless
you everyone else can read the no pizza sign.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna do this then.
First, we're gonna go to the hospital.
And now, you're pepper.
Welcome to Lego Island.
Because I want to get the red brick with here.
Oh.
You know, and then we can deliver the pizzas.
This is the run.
I just needed my skateboard, you know?
Hello, I didn't see you at first.
I see you now, of course, and I'm really glad you're here.
Why is he a chef all of a sudden?
Wait, I thought you weren't...
Oh, it's because I clicked on him.
This is bad.
Very bad.
This is when I was nine years old.
26 years ago.
I could do this.
Yes!
Give me the keys!
Okay, shoot.
Enter and return with you.
They'll know what to do.
Enter, return.
Come out here.
I need you, Calvin.
Outgoing.
Let's see.
I want to give him.
It's mine.
No, it's mine.
Since when does you wear that color?
I like the flower head.
Don't worry.
They'll get it together.
They always do.
Don't forget to take the ambulance head.
The ambulance head.
Right outside.
There we go.
And Peppa, try to go a little easy on the siren boy.
Some of us want to kill him.
Oh, there's a siren?
Be boobie!
Oh, I don't want to see this all over again, please.
Let me quit the cutscene, please.
I like how I can still interact with stuff.
Caparoni is in Lego Fortnite.
As an NPC in Lego Fortnite is currently celebrating the 15
years of Ninjago.
Oh, my God.
Trying to figure out your shortest route, it doesn't matter
which order.
Peep.
Someone there will tell you what to do.
All right, to the pizza.
To the pizza.
Some dude's choking.
Quick, do something.
Click on him, somebody.
I'm clicking, I'm clicking.
He's fine.
I love the way he just stops and smiles.
He's like, I'm choking.
Everybody just is smiley the whole time.
Why did he eat the whole shark?
Why did he do that?
The dog sounds so much like a human.
The dog being like, it was a bit.
Well, don't drop him!
You mean like that other guy?
Whatever happened to him.
Who?
The other guy!
We dropped him!
Well, don't drop him!
Okay.
To the police station!
Move, move, move!
There's plenty more to do.
If you need me, I'll be on the golf course.
Oh my gosh.
Where is that anyway?
The golf course?
Sir, is my profession a joke to you?
You're still in time.
No one's falling yet.
Hey, you see that's the way.
I guess we destroyed this leaf or something, but it's been
time for us ever since.
What I need you to do is get your clown boys over there to
hold the stretcher under the roof and catch my partner when
he falls.
I just wish I could cut, uh, skip some of these cutscenes.
All right, there we go.
Do a flip!
you can press space will that stop it no kidding okay let's
bring them on home oh not to my home of course it's just the
figure of speech all right first class driving no one will
feel a dang thing nice i like how also when they get
everybody out they're just like all stacked together.
Like that.
All my time here, I've never seen such good driving.
Oh, space scissors.
Yay!
Okay, let's go get my skateboard.
We'll start delivering some pizzas.
Yeah, we're so slow when we can't.
Okay.
Hopefully that gives us a red brick.
You guys, I'm going to be so honest.
It's so hard keeping my eyes open right now.
Oh my gosh.
I'm like You can't tell because I have my glasses on But I'm
like struggling
I'm so glad you're playing this game I haven't seen it since
I was a kid I started to think it was a dream
Okay Be careful Papa's got the seats to sense mean that
papa's got the six cents why why did we say that i do it i
am on my skateboard right okay i'm assuming yeah we're going
fast baby
no no we can make this we can make that there we go
Shut up.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, we just did it.
I'm free.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, we didn't have to do a bunch of the things.
Look up the word gullible.
Okay, now we can skip all this.
Wait, where'd my skateboard go, though?
Okay, we gotta go get it again, I think.
So we left it at the pizza.
Okay.
Oh, I thought we would have to redo everything.
The Brickster's loose!
He doesn't seem all that concerned.
He sees dead people.
He says, Vito!
All right.
Give me my skateboard.
Guys, it's not here.
Guys, where's my skateboard?
I think you're on the skateboard.
No, I'm...
I don't think so because I'm so slow, first of all, but
also...
You would see my hand if I wanted to...
If I were on it.
Is there nothing...
No, I should just be able to travel with it, no?
Oh, police station.
No.
Situation red.
We have a situation here and it isn't very pretty.
Keep it moving.
Hmm.
I feel like I'm so slow though, that's why I don't have it.
Oh, he's gonna be able to destroy so many buildings when
he's in the hospital.
All right, let me just write out a prescription here for the
Bricksters capture and done.
A prescription?
Hmm.
The Bricksters lose!
The Bricksters!
Yeah, you're off the skateboard.
I didn't think I was on.
The brickster's loose.
Everyone's freaking out, but...
But the island is, like, so tiny.
We could all gang together and get them, you know?
Well, at least you got here before too much damage.
we got most of the blockades down already there were no
blockades by the way we've got to hey folks small world
ain't it it's about to get smaller the bricksters stolen the
ambulance was stolen and we think the bricksters plan is to
take apart the town copy on that chief quick come after him
follow us like you guys have you guys have bikes i have
nothing man a i'll grab that brick for Oh my gosh.
Oh, oh shoot.
I'm so slow.
He's gonna absorb everything.
Whoa.
I'm shaking my bricks now.
Still there.
Hey, Pepper, did you order the brick?
The brick.
Okay.
All right.
Wait.
Where'd he go?
He's so fast.
I'm too slow.
Did he go up here?
No.
Did you order the...
Brick?
Did he go this way?
Where'd he go?
He went through the tunnel.
Oh my god.
Wait, this tunnel?
Wait, down here?
Where is it?
Oh, I see him.
Why can't I have a vehicle?
Why can't I have...
my...
Why can't I have my skateboard?
No, my beautiful garage is sinking!
I think we better stop him, that rickster still...
Don't you do it!
He did it in one go!
Wait!
Stop!
Thank you guys so much for the summertime!
Thank you!
Oh, oh my gosh.
He shoots!
He scores!
Okay, he's going around.
He's going around.
Can you just imagine I'm just a kid running through the
town?
Like literally like...
Huffing and puffing?
What are the cops doing?
Maybe you can catch a brick, but you can't catch me.
We're going round the island.
The Lego Island.
Don't do it!
I feel like the helicopter is going to be impossible.
Okay, but I know not to shoot so many pieces, I think.
All right, come on.
Was it just a koiki thing that he went to the...
this time.
Oh, I'm shaking my bricks now.
Oh, he almost tried.
Hey, Pepper, did you order the brick?
Did he, did I do that?
Did you order the brick?
Where's he going?
Did you order the...
What is he being by that?
Come on, why are we just letting this kid...
Okay.
This is the last one then.
All right.
Oh, no.
It's begun.
Oh.
I'll hide the rest, so I can rest.
Okay.
I'll turn the music down.
Hey, Vito, did you order the...
Don't say it.
All right, whistling time.
Now, though, I know that I can, like, click it from far
away.
I don't have to be right on top of it.
We still have to, like, get up here.
What did I order?
A knuckle sandwich.
Oh, my God.
Out of the way!
Please.
Oh.
Okay.
Can I see...
Is there any others that I could see from up here?
Is that one?
Oh, it is.
It was one.
Okay, that's two.
I think they're in different locations than before.
Out of the way!
Or maybe not.
That one felt like a different location.
But I might be crazy.
Speed run strats.
Absolutely.
Ah!
out of the way!
Okay, we can't see it from over here.
Uh...
At least we're not, like, preventing him from absorbing the
building, so...
Is that it?
Oh, it is.
Oh, they are in different spots, then.
Just a little bit.
Oh, here.
Oh, we did it!
Brilliant soups!
That was quick.
We're speed running, baby.
Okay.
Yeah.
Out of the way, out of the way, out of the way, out of the
way.
What's the point of having two different things if I can't
like go back and forth?
You know?
It all just goes one way.
This game is silly.
You're silly.
No, this game is really silly.
Smooth jazz town.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I'm nervous here.
I'm nervous.
Shoot donuts at the brick stair.
No.
That's not right.
Oh, I know.
Pizzas should be aimed at...
At...
The...
I know!
Shoot pizzas at the Brickster!
Donuts at Nick or Laura, and our island is saved!
Good luck!
And one more thing.
What was that?
Oh, yes!
Hurry!
Oh, Pepper, be careful upstairs!
Can you hear me, Pepper?
This is Mama!
It sounds like you're chewing a well!
Where's the cop?
Where are they?
Oh my god.
Where?
Okay, he ate one, I think.
Where are the police?
No!
Which way is he gonna go?
Which way?
Oh, there he is.
Where's the police?
No!
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
Eat!
Please!
Oh my god, please!
Please, please, please, God, please, God, please, God,
please, please, God, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please, please, please, oh, my God,
oh, my God, oh, my God, please, please, please, please,
please, oh, my God, I just turned my commendation off,
Why?
Please!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no!
No.
Okay, okay, this might be it, this might be it.
No!
Not bad, but not good.
I'm going to make it.
I don't think so.
Mama, we're not going to make it.
Please.
Is this a rage bait game?
I think.
Is this a rage bait game for real?
Oh my god.
They're going.
No, please.
Oh my god, please.
Please, please, God.
Why did he turn around?
They don't follow the pizza.
They don't follow the donuts.
I don't understand.
I don't understand the logic.
Why did he turn around?
I don't think there's any way to beat this gift.
I don't think it's possible!
Hey, Pepper!
It's Matt Lockett here!
Can you hurry up?
I'm getting dry rot down here!
Ah!
You have a one in me to remind you not to forget about those
donuts!
Cops get hungry too!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, please!
The preculator store!
Please!
Eat a donut!
I gotta tell you, this looks kinda funny from down here.
Like...
Like raining donut.
Seriously?
It's nonsensical.
I think it's no sense!
Turn around, please!
Turn around!
There you go.
Now use your head.
Did they just say that I'm now using my head?
Where's the cop?
They're gone!
We lost!
He's just stuck over there for some reason!
He's just going back and forth!
What was that?
Was that the break, sir?
Who's that?
Everybody, carry on, son.
I only have limited numbers of donuts and they're not...
I'm doing well, she says.
Everybody, she says I'm doing well.
I don't know, I seriously...
I don't know, everybody.
This is...
It's so over.
I think the pizza is the last place.
Please, everybody!
You're looking good, little buddy.
You're on that brickster like a parrot on a sesame seed
pizza.
Is this possible?
Well, it's not as bad as it is.
Oh, the buildings are the dots!
the donuts or the dots you can just start again or come back
later when you want to we'll be able to reconstruct i think
oh what am i saying but they don't follow them they don't
follow the donuts and they don't follow the pizza island so
start a new game or exit through those doors and come back
when you want to visit again
spam pizzas and donuts well where i didn't when I was seven.
Spam and make a trail to lead them around.
Okay, you have to rapidly click spam the donuts.
Okay, holy hell.
Oh my God, one more try.
Wait, I wanna see my cube.
And now you're Pepper.
Welcome to- Yay!
Okay, it worked.
Okay.
All right, Pepper.
And now you're Pepper.
I'm Pepper.
The worst part is following him in the damn ambulance.
Hello?
Okay.
Take that.
Let Lego.
Let le-lego.
Roadblock are not going anywhere.
Let Lego.
Let le-lego.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Yeah, we have to do it all over again, which is the worst
part.
Skate is only available when he delivers pizza.
It's the worst!
It's the actual worst!
Okay, wait, is he doing it?
Okay, okay, we gotta go.
Dargo, thank you!
Because we're so slow.
Oh my god.
The Bricksters loose!
He beats it in like 10 seconds and speed rat?
Speed rat?
Speed rat strat?
Not the speed rat!
The game rage baited me so hard, I actually woke up.
Like I was truly falling asleep.
And then...
Way to go.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Rage bait game of the year.
It's the mean, mean pizza machine.
He shoots, he scores!
This part he goes here.
I remember.
Third time's the charm.
Pizza makes Brickster slow.
Donut- yeah, they don't guide.
It's random if they catch him.
Well, okay.
So we just gotta spam it.
You may be able to catch a brick, but you can't catch me.
Hey, Pepper.
Deliver this.
What?
Where did that guy come from?
Alright.
Okay, so I thought it would lead them, but it doesn't.
So you just gotta make them really fast and him really slow.
But he does, though, what's the word?
He stops eating them after a while.
Brick?
No wonder I couldn't beat it as a kid if nothing worked
properly on XP.
Some people were invisible and you could only click things
at certain angles.
Oh my god.
Hey, hey, hey!
Whoa!
I'm shaking my bricks now.
He shoots, he scores!
Oh, is he heading to the secret area now?
I think he is.
I think he's heading to the... I think we're gonna hear the
whistle.
Q whistle.
Coming in high.
Whistle.
Yep, there he is.
Whistle coming in on three, two, oh.
Fine.
I'll hide the rest, so I can rest.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Alright, here we go.
Why does there have to be one at the very top?
Alright.
Spam pizza.
Spam donut.
Ooh.
Spam pizza.
Do it.
I can't.
I can't do it.
Hey!
Do your job!
Please God!
Okay.
Now from here, you can't see it's kind of randomized in a
way.
The one that was over there is not there now.
There's something in the sky.
Did you see that?
There's like a little brick in the sky.
Alright, we're gonna have to go back down and find them.
Oh, oops.
I'm not sorry.
I will not apologize.
Is there fall damage?
If we could fall.
Unfortunately, we can't even walk on the grass.
We are the most, like...
Great-laced Lego guy ever to ever exist.
Did I go the wrong way again?
I think I did.
My bad.
Goodie two bricks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Never will break the brick law.
I have eyes of a hawk, baby.
I'm guessing the last one is at the police station.
Because I don't hear it.
Oh, I hear it now.
He only got part of this building, so does it count?
Oh, wait.
I saw it.
Isn't that it?
This music.
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay, guys.
This is it!
We now have the means and a plan to capture that, that, that
poorly constructed brickster.
Pepper, as our best and most proven builder, quickly get to
the police station and build our helicopter.
Okay.
Shut up.
Shhh.
Let me work.
Let me do my job.
I'm an artist.
do let me do what i need to do oh okay that works let me
cook oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god Where's the police?
I'd rather call you.
Where's the police?
Krista is going to de-brick, sir.
Where is he?
There you go.
Oh my god.
Come down here!
How's it feel?
Maybe if we can, like, kind of keep him in the same spot,
you know?
Oh my god, please.
Please land.
No!
He's Zach!
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
I lost him I lost I lost oh there he is
Oh my god wait please please slow down slow down slow down
slow down slow down
Ah Oh we did it we did it
The Brickster is caught.
I repeat.
Harder than Dark Souls, absolutely.
Yeah, haul his ass to jail.
You and me, we did it.
We kept it together.
We are one.
Yeah, I held it together.
We're single choice like you!
I have a few.
And on behalf of the entire island, I wish to congratulate
you.
That's my hoshi.
Great work, beatotaku!
I'm sorry.
Let's see.
Oh, never mind the speech.
Let the celebration commence!
Oh my god.
I don't think she likes you doing that.
Oh that's not safe.
Oh my god.
You were so locked in for this.
Thank you, Cleo!
The Brickster is caught.
Brickster is caught.
Brick!
Pepper!
Minto.
Brilliant.
Stupendous.
Clean.
I can't thank you enough.
You saved us.
That's all I have to say about that.
You're the hero of the day.
I can't think of the words to express our thanks enough.
Accolades upon you.
Three chairs.
Hip, hip, hooray.
Hooray!
No, no, no, no.
That doesn't express it enough.
How about way to go?
Ooh.
I know.
Thanks.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Well, why not go see how well you did at the scorecube wall
while I think of something to say?
Or if you'd like to, play another game.
You know, open the book and- AI for the copter segment is
legitimately brain dead.
Spamming closer did the trick.
And now, oh, where was I?
Before the world started falling apart.
Oh, I remember the words to say, thank you.
You're a friend.
Ah, ah, pepperminto.
Pepperminto!
Guys, I count that as a win in our books.
We beat that game fair and square.
I can't believe the fact that everybody else can read the
sign means that they don't let him free.
But little pepper reads pizzazz because he's stupid as hell.
Our little guy is so dumb.
I got first in racing, first in boating, first in pizza,
first in law enforcement, first in gasoline, first in
hospital.
Like I think we just, we just knocked it out of the park
today.
So with that, it might be a little bit of a shorter stream,
but thank you all for joining me today for uh this absolute
hellscape of a of a game do we lego island to maybe in the
future can i play that one easily not sure what was in the
pizza i ate earlier there's no way this game is actually
this trippy it was way crazier than i remembered it that's
for sure Unfortunately, today's stream is going to be a
little bit shorter because I have some maid cafe.
I will be appearing at Asayoru tonight.
So, I have a maid cafe appearance that I got to get ready
for.
So, yeah.
And tomorrow as well.
But, of course, I'm streaming tomorrow, too.
Just kind of doubled up.
Yes, yes.
Thank you for the fun stream.
Thank you!
Thank you for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
I had so much fun Oh Oh I clicked out of the game I was like
what's happening Let's see
But yeah Oh this was Interesting It was fun for sure It was
like part of Part of I don't think I beat this game I
definitely had it But I don't think I beat it Have lots of
fun at the cafe Thank you I will
ending at all so now i've i have reclaimed this from look at
the way it's like framed makes it look like pepper is like
he is the god of of lego island i was too dumb to understand
how it worked well hopefully if you never beat this game
when you were a kid i've i hopefully have a um satisfied
your curiosity a little bit.
Hope you're having a good day.
I sure am.
Ever since I saw the Game Awards last night, Ace Combat.
Hey, let's go!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
So excited.
It was a fever dream.
I'm not sure if I was hallucinating.
Smash Boo feel better.
I'll be at Asayodu tomorrow.
See you there.
See you there, Tony!
Yarn.
When you're ready to end, the computer mouse click on end
stream button should be using a program like obs yark thank
you captain so yeah this was certainly a game absolutely was
excited to see at the cafe tomorrow see you there matchy i'm
gonna take a nap before tonight i don't know why i'm so
tired but thank you guys Thank you so much.
Tri-Princess, thank you for the...
Oh no, I saw it.
I don't know if it'll come through, though, before I end.
So, thank you!
I have a new respect for the Lego movie after seeing this.
I just want to know...
What was going on in their brains to create this?
You know?
Like, what?
What?
Do we really want to know?
Just, I would like to say just whimsy, a full dosage of
whimsy.
Yeah, I think so.
Anyways, Otsumito!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Otsumito, otsumito, otsumito!
Otsumito!
See you guys later.
Bye-bye.
Oh, wait.
Before I go, here's your pizza.
Eat up!